[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Monsieur le Premier
Ministre mesdames messieurs les
ministres chers collègues comme la
plupart des collègues du groupe Liot je
suis allé sur un barrage d'agriculteur
en colère ces derniers jours pour leur
témoigner notre solidarité notre soutien
mon passage n'était ni organisé par des
services de la préfecture ni filtré issu
d'un territoire rural fils d'agriculteur
et ayant à l'esprit les graves
difficultés qu'ils affrontent et qui
n'ont fait que croître j'ai vu les
visages graves
comme pour les professionnels de santé
les artisans ou les enseignants j'ai été
frappé par une colère amplifiée par
l'absence d'écoute et de
concertation après la crise des gilets
jaunes celle des retraites des banlieux
cette mobilisation c'est encore et
encore un appel à changer les modes de
décision et une soif de transformation
de notre logiciel
démocratique vous n'anticipez jamais et
vous ne savez pas écouter vous êtes dans
l'autre soie depuis is les beaux
quartiers de Paris coupé de la réalité
de nos
territoires que nous demandent nos
concitoyens que le travail P enfin et
que vous maîtrisiez l'inflation touchant
de plus en plus de Françaises et de
français en difficulté mais aussi une
justice et un accompagnement social et
non pas marche ou crève comme il m'a
semblé l'entendre il y a quelques
instants de la simplification le stock
des normes à triplé en 20 ans des normes
qui s'additionnent se contredisent
mettre fin à la technocratie en folie
enfin un état qui se consacre qui se
concentre sur ses priorité seul 6 % de
l'investissement sur le régalien on
comprend mieux pourquoi nos hôpitaux la
justice l'enseignement nos commissariat
sont dans un aussi mauvais état et que
l'on ne prépare pas l'avenir de nos
jeunes y compris au plan environnemental
cette crise institutionnelle ne peut pas
se ne peut se résoudre que par une
réforme profonde de l'État la priorité
un véritable choc de décentralisation
plus de consultation avec le référendum
un parlement plus respecté décors
intermédiaires plus écouté des dépenses
publiques les plus importantes de tous
les pays occidentaux chez nous et des
services publics qui fonctionne de moins
en moins bien quel
paradoxe les Français attendent des
mesures fortes sur le pouvoir d'achat le
partage de la valeur ajoutée et de la
participation ils veulent des hôpitaux
qui fonctionnent des épates qui ne
soient pas des mourroirs et des bonnes
écoles qui ne soient pas réservé qu'aux
plus riches comme le président s'était
engagé nous demandons une vraie loi
grand âge une vraie politique du
logement permett aux Français de se
loger soutenir la construction s'engager
enfin dans la rénovation énergétique
mais par une politique du logement en
regroupant et en simplifiant tous les
dispositifs la seule réponse enfin une
prise en compte des territoires
ultramarins comme nos territoires ruraux
toujours oubliés et N
nous demandons une véritable loi de
programmation pour nos territoires
ultramarins les coupures d'eau sont
insupportables comme les difficulté
d'accès aux soins dû notamment à la
double insularité je ne vous ai pas
entendu non plus monsieur le Premier
ministre sur l'aménagement des
territoires vous venez de prononcer
votre discours de politique générale 3
semaines après votre nomination un
catalogue en oubliant petit détail que
vous n'avez toujours pas de majorité
votre gouver ement n'est toujours pas
constitué vous n'avez pas osé d'ailleurs
demander la confiance de notre assemblée
vos déclarations choc les surenchères
médiatiques et leur mise en scène où les
réponses à l'immédiateté des réseaux
sociaux ne seront contentés nos
concitoyens à la recherche d'un CAP un
véritable développement enfin humain
économique social et environnementale et
par une méthode claire celle de l'écoute
et de la
concertation mais cela a fait 7 ans que
vous êtes au pouvoir et même si cela
fait déjà 7 ans que vous êtes au pouvoir
il n'est jamais trop tard pour bien
faire pour travailler sur les priorités
pour notre pays ces trois prochaines
années nous y sommes prêts pas une liste
à la prêverre pour associer tous les
corps intermédiaires et les forces vives
de notre pays nous vous demandons un
calendrier précis sur les réformes
institutionnelles le transfert de
compétences y compris réglementaires aux
grandes collectivités et leur autonomie
fiscale c'est la clé de la réussite pour
la France sans oublier la question de
l'autonomie pour la Corse nous croyons
dur comme faire monsieur le Premier
ministre que notre pays n'est pas
ingouvernable que notre pays est
réformable et que si et rien n'est
inéluable sous réserve en fin que vous
entendiez les Françaises et les Français
avec le président Macron vous êtes
maintenant au pied du mur il y a deux
portes la première vous permettra de
monter un à un tous les escaliers du
redressement de notre pays à condition
de le faire dans la concertation la
deuxième s'ouvre face à un grand
précipice un saut qui sera pour notre
pays sans parachute écoutez Monsieur le
Premier Ministre écoutez les Françaises
et les Français et surtout ne vous
trompez pas de
porte merci beaucoup monsieur le
président